[Música]
es el momento de repasar la economía
aquí en directo a América edición
nocturna Para ello contamos un día más
con nuestro compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge bienvenido a este estudio y vamos
a empezar en Reino Unido que está
haciendo está siendo noticia económica
porque la crisis política parece escalar
con la renuncia del ministro de finanzas
el exministro de relaciones exteriores
Jeremy home es el nuevo ministro de
finanza de Reino Unido la oficina de la
primera ministra británica listross lo
confirmó tras la salida de cuasi
cuarting tras solo 38 días en el cargo y
como parte de su último intento para
tranquilizar a los mercados financieros
por este nuevo rumbo económico La Movida
de trolls Busca que Hunt ponga las
finanzas públicas en un camino
sostenible sin sacrificar Eso sí su
controvertido paquete de recortes
Fiscales que llevó a la administración a
esta crisis económica los recortes
Fiscales por 45 mil millones de libras
esterlinas hizo que la moneda local
cayera a mínimos históricos frente al
Dólar y sembró bastante nerviosismo el
sector financiero y político de ese país
incluso obligó al banco de Inglaterra
intervenir para evitar una crisis
económica Eso dijo la primera ministra
hoy le he pedido ayer en mi Hunt que sea
el nuevo ministro de finanzas es uno de
los funcionarios y parlamentarios más
experimentados y respetados y comparte
mis convicciones y ambiciones para este
país
entregará el plan fiscal de medio plazo
final de este mes incluida nuestra
garantía de precios de energía que
protegerá este invierno a la gente de
Los Altos precios de la energía
y dirigirá nuestra misión de crecimiento
incluidas las reformas que necesitamos
en nuestra economía de la oferta
Jorge anuncio de nuevo plan fiscal por
parte de lis tras pero será suficiente
esta medida para mejorar la situación
económica del país la verdad es que los
problemas van muchísimo más allá de
estos nombramientos políticos la
inflación allí es de casi al 10% anual
mientras el desempleo en aumento
organismos como el fondo monetario
internacional pronosticaron desde hace
que Reino Unido iba a enfrentar un
crecimiento lento y alta inflación uno
de los grandes problemas es la deuda de
Reino Unido allí la deuda es de casi 2,4
billones de dólares el 96% sobre el
producto interno bruto los expertos
prevén que la deuda podría triplicarse
en 50 años por eso se deben aumentar
impuestos pero lo que quiere hacer
trozos es recortarlos para afrontar la
inflación y la crisis energética
escuchemos qué opina el economista
Daniela calle sobre este intento de
calmar a los mercados
lo primero que tenemos que entender es
que la debilidad de la libra y en la
necesidad de intervención del Banco
Central no tienen nada que ver con lo
que hago de hacerles por un presupuesto
sino es la consecuencia de más de una
década de exceso monetario en el que se
ha estado disfrazando el riesgo
particularmente en los bonos soberanos y
es un riesgo que está apareciendo no
solamente en el Reino Unido sino también
en Europa la eurozona Noruega Japón
Incluso en China lo segundo que Debemos
entender es que el gobierno del estrés
está cometiendo un grave error al
cambiar su política fiscal simplemente
por hacer una
supuesta intencionalidad de calmar a los
mercados porque lo que está dando es una
señal de debilidad y además de dar una
señal de debilidad no está entendiendo
que
el problema fiscal del Reino Unido no lo
ha creado este gobierno ni este
presupuesto sino más de una década de
estar constantemente monetizando el
déficit lo que no se debe hacer es esto
que se llama muy mal presupuestos
expansivos el presupuesto expansivo se
le llama a gastar mucho más y eso es un
error y es un error en un periodo de
inflación porque perpetúa la inflación
entonces lo que hay que hacer es reducir
el gasto público pero pese a lo que dice
Daniel en la calle parece que listras
está dispuesta a seguir con este plan y
es que pese a que retrocedió en el plan
de recortes Fiscales Dross reiteró que
sus políticas eran las que el país
necesitaba para estimular el crecimiento
económico la primera ministra evitó las
preguntas sobre Por qué debía seguir en
el cargo cuando ella y cuarten eran
igual de responsables del plan económico
del gobierno y de sus repercusiones su
próxima gran prueba será este lunes
cuando se reanuden las operaciones
mercado financieros tomando en cuenta
que el banco de Inglaterra terminó con
su intervención de emergencia para
estabilizar los precios de los bonos a
largo plazo y proteger los fondos de
pensiones pues Jorge el lunes estaremos
atentos a lo que nos cuentes de lo que
llega de las noticias económicas desde
Inglaterra Muchas gracias por este
repaso económico y te invito tanto a ti
como a los espectadores a seguir con
nuestro programa una semana en el mundo